foreign
[Music]
Pikesville Maryland used to be in a 24
000 square foot space in this building
now it's moved across the street to a
space that's less than half the size
and with the downsizing came a new look
and new books chosen specifically for
this store's customers it's all part of
Barnes and Noble's strategy to tailor
each of the company's more than 600
locations to local tastes Barnes and
Noble is adopting the strategy of
independent bookstores that it once put
out of business here's how the
Bookseller is implementing its new
approach and Wyatt thinks this new
strategy will sell more books
this is the economics of Barnes and
Noble
Barnes Noble was first founded in 1873.
in 1971 Leonard Riggio acquired the
company which set off a period of growth
the retailer went public in 1993 in an
era when it was opening Superstores
across the country in the 1990s and
2000s Barnes and Noble bookstores really
looked like large supermarkets filled
with books usually anchoring strip
centers in the suburbs or rural areas
and whether in Phoenix or Maryland or
Ohio the stores had the same books with
the same furniture and the same layout I
either had one floor or it had two if I
had two it had enormous sense collectors
going out with this huge sort of open
space in the middle to an upper floor
that model happened to be extremely
scalable they were trying to fill their
stores with books and infrastructure at
the lowest cost possible so they wanted
to order all the same types of
bookshelves the same type of furnishings
and decorations and other accoutrements
so the company grew and fast those huge
stores carried more books at lower
prices than independent bookstores we
all remember the rom-com you got mail
Joe Fox I'm in the book business I am in
the book business so many closed when
Barnes Noble came to town they weren't
able to compete with the title selection
or prices that Barnes Noble offered but
big stores and large inventories weren't
enough to save Barnes and Noble from a
digital threat Amazon was able to offer
kind of like Barnes Noble had in the
past a huge selection of titles at lower
prices than Barnes Noble could because
it didn't have the cost of real estate
and other costs that Barnes Noble was
shouldering and it sunk a lot of money
trying to keep Pace particularly in Nook
it's e-reader business this to your
story
but nothing helped stop the bleeding the
company's Revenue has declined since
2012. then in 2019 hedge fund Elliott
Management Corporation acquired the
chain and installed James Dawn who led
British retailer waterstones and founded
his own independent bookstore.books as
CEO it felt entirely intuitive to me
that you allow each bookstore to run as
an independent book so they will create
much more interesting much more Dynamic
much more engaging bookstores and that
meant reminding people about the appeal
of in-person versus online shopping what
you're missing is the opportunity to
kind of read the book flaps of all the
other books that are there and maybe get
recommendations from the local
Bookseller who's working there
company says it wanted to emphasize the
experience of visiting a physical
bookstore
so its new strategy strips stores of the
cookie cutter look and feel that it
helps the chain grow its revenue and
store account some locations have moved
on from The Big Box model to smaller
stores and in these smaller spaces there
are reconfiguring the stores so that
they're more of a maze and less of a
supermarket aisle plus the company says
each individual store has more autonomy
over what books to order and how to
display them here at the Pikesville
Maryland location the store manager says
that customers like romance books from
Black authors and lots of fiction so the
large romance section is at the front of
the store and there's a huge display
right in the center celebrating Black
History Month store managers can also
choose how to run promotions like this
buy one get one 50 off deal on specific
fiction books chosen by the team here
Brooklyn has a very different
demographic very different set of
customers a very different set of book
interests to let's say somebody in
Alabama in Georgia who is the best
person to judge what those particular
communities want to buy it's the
booksellers in those communities the
company has also been listening to its
store managers on wider Trends manga was
a small part of our assortment we had
maybe five six Bays of books on manga
And yet when these booksellers were
reorganizing their stores they were
coming back to us saying we want to do
38. you know we want to do 42 which was
just I almost sort of incomprehensible
except that's what they said their
customers would respond to Dart also
used this localizing strategy to turn
around British bookstore chain water
stones which reported a 42.91 million
pound loss across 268 stores in 2012.
compared to a 16.32 million pound profit
across 278 stores six years later
the two businesses are on paper
identical it had had identical histories
and had reached an identical point of
failure that's why Barnes Noble
relinquished some controlled individual
stores but that comes with its own set
of challenges for the company you could
walk into a bookstore and find out that
it's really not doing well the managers
choices aren't appealing to customers
and books aren't selling still Barnes
Noble says the strategy is promising for
the first time in more than a decade the
company is planning on opening more
stores than it closes in 2023 we've seen
a balancing in which much higher
percentage of our sales are coming from
books and books are growing really very
dramatically if you run better
bookstores you sell more books
thank you
foreign
[Music]